can we talk about
um europa
is there um so maybe can you talk about
the intuition the hope that people have
about life being in europa
maybe also what are the things we know
about it
what are things to you that are
interesting about that particular moon
of jupiter
sure yeah europa is from many
perspectives one of the really
interesting
places in the solar system among the
solar system moons so there are a few
there has there's a lot of interest in
looking for or understanding the
potential for life to evolve in the
subsurface oceans
i think it's fairly widely accepted that
the chances of life evolving on the
surfaces
of really anything in the solar system
is very low
the radiation environment is
too harsh um and there's there's just
not liquids on the surface of most of
these things and it's
canonically accepted that liquids are
required for life
um and so the subsurface oceans in
addition to maybe titan's atmosphere the
subsurface oceans of the icy satellites
uh are one of the most plausible places
in the solar system for life to evolve
um europa and enceladus are interesting
because
for many of the big satellites so
ganymede and callisto
also satellites of jupiter also are
thought to have subsurface oceans
but um they are so they have these ice
shells and then there's an ocean
underneath the ice shell
but on those moons around ganymede we
think that there's another ice shell
underneath
and then there's rock and the reason
that that is a problem for life
is that your ocean is probably just pure
water because it's trapped between two
big shells of ice so europa
doesn't have this ice shell at the
bottom of the ocean we think
and so the water and rock are in direct
interaction and so that means that you
can
basically dissolve a lot of material out
of the rock you potentially have this
hydrothermal activity that's injecting
energy and nutrients for life to survive
and so this
water interface is is considered really
important
for the potential habitability
as a small side you kind of said that
it's canonically assumed that
uh light water is required for life
is it possible to have life uh like in
the volcano
i remember people were i did like a
national geographic program or something
kind of hypothesizing that you can
really have life anywhere
so as long as there's a source of heat a
source of energy
do you think it's possible to have life
in a volcano
like no water
i think anything's possible
i think it's so water it doesn't have to
be
water that's sort of you can tell as you
identified i phrased that really
carefully it's canonically accepted that
because we recognize that you know
scientists recognize that we have no
idea
what broad range of life could be out
there and all we really have is our
biases of life as we know it
but for life as we know it it's very
helpful to have or even
necessary to have some kind of liquid
and preferably a polar solvent that can
actually dissolve molecules something
like water so the case of liquid methane
on titan is less ideal from that
perspective
but you know liquid magma if it stays
liquid long enough for life to evolve
you have a heat source you have a liquid
you have nutrients in theory that checks
your three
classic astrobiology boxes
um that'd be fascinating i mean it'd be
fascinating if it's possible to detect
it easily
how would we detect if there is life on
europa
is um is it possible to do in a
non-contact way
from a distance through telescopes and
so on
or do we need to send robots and do some
drilling
i think realistically you need to do the
drilling
there's so europa also has these long
tectonic features on its surface where
it's thought that
um there's potential for water from the
ocean to be somehow making its way
up onto the surface and you could
imagine some out there
scenario where there's bacteria in the
ocean it's somehow working its way up
through the ice shell it's spilling out
on the surface
it's being killed by the radiation but
your instrument could detect some
spectroscopic signature of that
dead bacterium but that's you know
that's many ifs and assumptions
that's a hope because then you don't
have to do that much drilling you can
collect from the surface
right or even i'm thinking even remotely
oh remotely
yeah that's sad that there's a
single cell civilization living
underneath all that ice
trying trying trying to get up trying to
get out
so enceladus gives you a slightly better
chance of that
because enceladus is a is a moon of
saturn
and it's broadly similar to europa in
some ways it's an icy satellite it has a
subsurface ocean that's probably
in touch with the rocky interior but it
has these massive
geysers at its south pole where it's
spewing out material that appears to be
originating
all the way from the ocean and so in
that case
you could potentially fly through
that plume and scoop up that material
and hope that at the velocities you'd be
scooping it up you're not destroying any
signature of the life you're looking for
um but let's say that you have some
ingenuity and can come up with a way to
do that you know it potentially gives
you
a more direct opportunity at least to
try to measure
those bacteria directly can you tell me
a little more
on uh how do you pronounce it uh
enceladus enceladus can you tell me a
little bit more about enceladus
like uh we've been talking about way too
much about jupiter
saturn doesn't get enough no no
uh saturn doesn't get as much love so
what's what's enceladus
is that the most exciting moon of saturn
depends on your
perspective um it's very exciting from a
astrobiology perspective i think
enceladus and
titan are the two most unique and
interesting moons of saturn that
definitely
both get the most attention also from
the life perspective
um so what's the more likely titan
or enceladus for life
if you were to uh bet all your money in
terms of like investing
which to investigate what what are the
difference between the two
that are interesting to you yeah so
the potential for life in each of those
two places is very
different so titan is the the one place
in the solar system where you might
imagine again all of this is so
speculative but you might imagine
life evolving in the atmosphere so the
from
a biology perspective titan is
interesting because
it forms complex organic molecules in
its atmosphere
it has a dense atmosphere it's actually
denser than earth's it's the only moon
that has
what an atmosphere denser than earth and
it's got tons of methane in it what
happens is that methane gets irradiated
it breaks up and it reforms
with other things in the atmosphere it
makes these
complex organic molecules and it's
effectively doing prebiotic
chemistry in the atmosphere while still
being
freezing cold uh yes okay
what what would that be like would that
be pleasant for humans to
hang out there it's just really cold
there's nowhere in the solar system that
would be pleasant for humans
um it would be cold you couldn't breathe
the air um
but colonization-wise if there's an
atmosphere isn't that a big plus
there's still a ton of radiation
okay so okay so titan
that that's a really nice feature that
the life could be in the atmosphere
because then it's
it's that might be remotely observable
or certainly is more accessible if you
visit
okay so uh what about enceladus so that
would be
still in the ocean right an enceladus
has
the advantage like i said of spewing
material out of its south pole so you
could collect it but it has
the disadvantage of the fact that we
don't actually really understand
how its ocean could
stay froze or sorry could stay globally
liquid
over the age of the solar system and so
there are some models that say
that it's going through this cyclical
evolution
where the ocean freezes completely and
thaws completely and the orbit sort of
um oscillates in and out of these
eccentricities um and in that case
the potential for life ever occurring
there in the first place is a lot lower
because if you only have an ocean for
100 million years
is that enough time um and it also
means there might be mass extinction
events if it does occur
right it just freezes again very sad man
i'm
this is very depressing all the like
slaughter of life
elsewhere
you